assalamualaikum guys and welcome to
smile to Jannah a lot of people have
been messaging me to make a video about
what's going on in Kashmir
before I begin here's a quick background
indian-administered Kashmir is a Muslim
majority area which is under Indian rule
now this mismatch of leadership and
demographic has led to the people
rebelling and wanting to join either
Pakistan or being outright independent
either way being against the Indian rule
now this has made the area very unstable
closing India to employ a whopping half
million troops here making it one of the
most militarized areas on the planet now
India has repeatedly violated Human
Rights which is a very mild way of
putting it and using extreme force to
suppress any opposition what's going on
now now there's two incidents and we're
gonna focus on the first incident this
was an annual Hindu 45-day pilgrimage to
a Himalayan cave shrine yeah and this
was taking place so India claimed that
it received intelligence suggesting an
attack on these pilgrimage routes and so
asked all of the pilgrims and tourists
to evacuate straightaway the second
incident was the Indian Army said it had
foiled an attempt by Pakistani militants
across the border of a Pakistani Kashmir
and Indian Kashmir killing several
attackers pakistan denies this and
accuses india of attacking civilians
across this border line in an area
called the Neelum Valley with cluster
munitions which is in violation of
international law again India
this now in war the first casualty is
truth
someone's clearly lying and using this
to further their agenda now they know
that the international community can't
verify who it is and it's gonna be
India's word against Pakistan is world
so in the end is gonna come down to the
strength of propaganda and the influence
that the country has and that's
naturally in a favor of India one of the
biggest areas we have to counter
terrorism I need to neutralize that
terrorist one terrorist has been
neutralized
terror threat some terrorists may have
been filtrated nasty with the suspicious
facts which point towards a hostile
takeover of some kind from India okay
now there's been terrorist attacks that
happened in the area before but consider
the following it's already half a
million troops there but an additional
10,000 have been affected mobile
networks and the internet has been
restricted schools have been closed
curfew restrict restrictions have been
added so people are literally shut out
from the outside world from each other
local politicians are put under house
arrest even if they're pro India okay
now let's look at the time considering
Pakistan is working with the u.s. to
resolve the conflict in Afghanistan that
could mean a problem for India as that
would mean Pakistan would be more
focused on Kashmir
number two you got independent status
coming up so in the lower light of
independence day those terrorists will
and will need to be neutralized and
ensure that this time every punch I've
got in the valley will be celebrating
Independence Day in a very big way
some might say India is acting in
self-defense
but the majority of the evidence says
otherwise and points to India being the
aggressor
number one India has refused third party
mediation even if it be with the u.s. to
such a degree that Indians were furious
when Trump gave the impression that Modi
asked him for mediation
number two and this is DeBakey article
370 has now been revoked
yeah and this is causing the most
outrage this was what people were
worried about the most now this was the
condition with which indian-administered
Kashmir agreed to join with India in the
first place yeah
this article allowed Kush me to have a
degree of freedom and independence from
India but Hindu nationalists have been
fighting against this for a very long
time the Prime Minister being a Hindu
nationalist himself announced this -
when he was running for leadership so
now he's just reenacting what he
promised
number three considering the area is
majority Muslim the best bet for India
would be to change the demographic yeah
because it's more difficult trying to
win those people over so there's two
ways that they can do this firstly
install illegal settlements like
Israel's done in Palestine as hinted by
the BJP leader and secondly to revoke
article 35 a and that's just a ticking
time bomb article 35 a prevents people
from outside the state from buying land
in the territory yeah now naturally when
this is revoked this would get like an
influx of rich Indians literally buying
out Kashmir and that would inevitably
lead it to be a part of India when these
two things are revoked naturally there's
going to be a backlash from the people
so that's you know you got all these
troops there that are there to kind of
suppress any outbursts do with the
curfews and you're not allowed to meet
or organize any public rallies and the
borders being tightened up between the
apakah stance or Pakistan won't be able
to assist either so it does seem like a
hostile takeover India is playing a very
small game it's not revealing too much
it's putting its foundation in place so
when this house
takeover happens is gonna be very little
resistance so in this month of the
ledger I do ask you guys to make dua for
our brothers and sisters the iron
cashmere if there's anything that I
missed out you guys got any more
resources put them in the comments in
Sharla until next time
Salam aleikum